TWENTY THIRD ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE OF
REGULAR ORDER HEARING FIRST. WE
ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND START
ALTHOUGH WE DO NEED MORE
MEMBERS TO COME DOWN SO THAT WE
CAN DO THIS- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THERE'S
ALWAYS. BIGELOW BLOOM BONTA.
WROTE CALDERON. WE LIKE YEAH
TRICIA. DO YOU. THE HERE EGGMAN.
FONG GABRIEL HERE GARCIA
MAIENSCHEIN PETRIE-NORRIS.
QUIRK HERE RIVAS. SPEAKER OF.
IT IS WITH. ALL RIGHT WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM BUT TO ME BILLS
CAN BE HARD TO GET A OF WE
pDON'T MORE DE HERE SO. HOPING
MEMBERS HERE THAT COME TO. WE
HAVE A TOTAL FIFTH BILLS
CONSIDERED MORNING ON THE RADIO
ORDER. BEFORE WE BEGIN- I WILL
GO AHEAD AND WELCOME OUR NEWEST
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN DOLLY BUT WHEN
SHE GETS HERE WILL WELCOME HER
OFFICIALLY- THERE IS ALWAYS
EIGHT OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT REGULAR ORDER HEARINGS
AT THE END- I WANNA REMIND
PEOPLE THAT AFTER WE GET
THROUGH THE REGULAR ORDER
HEARING WE HAVE TO MOVE ON TO
THE SUSPENSE FILES SO- THE
LONGER YOU TALK. THE MORE BILLS
DIE. AND YOU MIGHT WANT THAT
BUT CONSIDER IT CLOSELY I'M.
CAN I GET A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT KIM. SECOND THAT'S A
GOOD CAN YOU READ THE CONTENT
CALENDAR. AB. 231-993-1205
TWELVE SIXTY THREE FOURTEEN
SIXTY NINE IN FIFTEEN TWELVE.
WE YOU DO HAVE. ALL RIGHT THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL THANK
YOU I'M SORRY FOR A LITTLE OUT
OF PRACTICE TODAY I KNOW- I
WANT TO NOTE THAT THE FOLLOWING
BILLS HAVE BEEN PULLED FROM THE
AGENDA AND THEY'VE EITHER BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR OR THE
COMMITTEE OR A COMBINATION OF
ALL AB TWENTY TWO BURKE AB
TWELVE TEN LOW IN AB SEVENTEEN
TWELVE LEX SO THOSE WILL NOT BE
ON THE AGENDA TODAY. WITH THAT.
WE WILL MOVE TO MISTER LEVINE.
FOURTEEN FORTY ONE. MR LEVINE.
THIS ENJOYS IT YOU PASS
RECOMMENDATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
FOURTEEN MILLION ONE UPDATES
LAWS WE HAVE ENACTED AGAIN AND-
I'M GLAD THAT YOU GUYS. ARE
EXCITED ABOUT IT. GREAT
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. ANY
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO KNOW MAKE SURE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE DO NOT
A FILE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
SEEN- NO QUESTIONS WHICH I
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
COMMITTEE THANK YOU THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. MISTER
RODRIGUEZ LOOKS LIKE YOUR NEXT.
MISTER RODRIGUEZ YOU HAVE AB
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE IT ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION. IF YOU
MOVE THE YELL AND THAT WAS
EIGHT EIGHT MOTION BY MISS
KOREA AS SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK
YOU ME BEGIN. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT A. B.
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE TODAY THIS
BILL REQUIRE CAMPUS AFFILIATE
FRATERNITIES AND SORORITIES TO
ANOTHER REPORT AND PUBLICIZE.
INFORMATION ON MISCONDUCT AND
CITATIONS GRADE POINT AVERAGE
ACTIVE AND YOU MEMBERS AND MANY
REYES ON THE SCHOOL WEBSITES.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I RESPECT
THAT STRUGGLE ON A. B. FIFTY
FIVE ARE THERE SPEAKER IN
SUPPORT. SPEAKERS AND- PART OF
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO FIVE.
WE'RE GOOD. THAT GETS OUT ON A
CALL THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ
THANK YOU. MR ARAMBULA. YOUR
PRESENT TEEN ASSUME ON AB.
FIFTY FOR ONE. THANK YOU MAY
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY ONE MOVED TO MAKE A
MOTION DOCTOR AND IT'S A BY
MISTER. ARE YOUR CHAIR I VOTE
EITHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT GOOD
MORNING AT ABOUT THE BEHALF THE
CAL. SO SEE OF REALTORS FOR THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL THANK YOU
IN SUPPORT. CATALINA SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION IN
SUPPORT. OTHER SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT FINANCE
NO FILE. I SEE NO QUESTIONS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM ABOUT A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU. MISTER
CUNNINGHAM AB FIFTEEN NINETY
NINE ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW IN A
SECOND BY MISTER ROWE MORNING
MANAGER MEMBERS IN FIFTEEN
NINETY NINE CLARIFIES AND
CLOSES A LOOPHOLE RELATING TO
PUBLIC DISCLOSURE OF POLICE
RECORDS IN CIRCUMSTANCES SEXUAL
ASSAULT UNDER COLOR OF LAW I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
SPEAKER IN SOME. GOOD MORNING
I'M BRITNEY WITHIN THE BURDEN
OF OUR SITE WITH HEALTH NEWS
PUBLISHERS ALSO AND WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL. SPEAKERS OPPOSITION.
ONE MAN CHAIR MEMBERS FRENCH
GERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION- WE
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE- UNLIKE WHAT IT SAYS-
IT BEING A MERITORIOUS FIX. TO
ENSURE ALL INFORMATION
REGARDING SEXUAL SALTS. AND
THAT'S OT THE CASE BECAUSE
THIS WILL. INCLUDE INFORMATION
THAT IS NOT- ACCURATE AS FAR AS
ASSAULTS GO THIS IS GOING TO
RELEASE INFORMATION THAT OF AN
ALLEGATION WHETHER IT'S
SUBSTANTIATED OR NOT AND SO WE
REMAIN OPPOSED THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS RAINY PERRY WITH
THEIR READING ASSOCIATES ON
BEHALF OF POOR ACT THE
ASSOCIATION HI PATROL AND THE
SAMPER DINO SURE SOME PLEASE.
AND WE'RE OPPOSED TO THE BILL
IT OPENS UP FOR THE FIRST TIME.
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST PEACE
OFFICERS WORKING WITH THE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE ON SOME
AMENDMENTS- THIS COMES FROM A
SINGLE ISSUE IN THE DISTRICT.
OF MISTER CUNNINGHAM AND WE
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO FIND. CASES
SIMILAR TO THIS STATEWIDE AND
WE'RE TRYING TO FIND A STILL
BUT THIS ISN'T MERE ALLEGATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I FINANCE
NO FILE NO DOCTOR COURT HAS A
QUESTION FIRST OF ALL I THINK
IT'S VERY I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT BILL- WHILE IT'S TRUE
TRUE THAT THIS REACHED THIS
REFERS TO ALLEGATIONS WHAT
PERSON CAN PROVE IT TO THE
BALLOT IS EMPLOYED WITH THAT A
C. B. CLEAR AND THEN FORWARD.
ISRAEL COULD THE AUTHOR KIND OF
LINE THIS SOME HIS THOUGHTS
WITH TO OP THAT WAS ENDING
THEIR COMMENTS. SIR WE ARE
WORKING WITH GREW TRIP. THAT
ARE CURRENTLY NOT. ON LANGUAGE
IT WOULD. ADDRESS OF THE CUTS
THAT RAISED BUT WE ARE SEEK TO
X. TO POWER THIS NEAR
ALLEGATIONS. WHAT WE ARE
ATTEMPTING TO DO IS. CLOSE A
LOOPHOLE THAT EXIST IN THE
CURRENT STATUTE WHERE BY
SOMEBODY IS ACCUSED OF. SERIOUS
SEXUAL ASSAULT UNDER COLOR OF
LAW USING THEIR BADGE TO COMMIT
A SEXUAL ASSAULT. UNDER CURRENT
LAW CAN RESIGN. AND AVOID
HAVING THE RECORDS OF
INVESTIGATION TO THAT ASSAULT
EVER CLOSE TO PUBLIC. I DON'T.
THE INTENT BEST TEAM TWENTY
ONE. ENACTED THAT LAWS TAPI
ISN'T ALONG MANY OF YOU. SO GO.
TRYING TO WILL PULL WAS X. BY
CASE THE DID ACT FIRM I JUST I
THINK IT WILL BE THE LAST OF
THESE CASES WE THIS FOR WERE
WORK WITH THEM I THINK WE'LL
END UP ON WITH WITH SOMETHING
THAT WILL WORK FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION LEVEL AND THE
OFFICER TO BE FOR BECAUSE AT
THE END OF THE DAY WE'RE
SEEKING TO THE PUBLIC. IS STATE
FINDINGS OF SO. ASSAULT ON THE
JOB. SO COULD WE EXPECT TO SEE
SOME AMENDMENTS WITH ARRIVES IN
THE SENATE WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON EXCHANGING LANGUAGE WITH ALL
THE STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND YES
I ANTICIPATE THAT WILL HAPPEN.
OKAY HE SAID THAT AND I WOULD
PROBABLY JUST URGE SOME URGENCY
TO MAKING SURE THAT YOU GET
THAT DONE ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. JUSTICE THAT WE HAVE
A CASE LIKE THIS IN A WORD WHEN
I WAS ON CITY COUNCIL- I'M NOT
TO PRY SOMEBODY COULDN'T FIND
REFERENCE FULL TO IT BECAUSE IT
REMAIN IN THE RECORD. YEAH IT'S
NOT IN THE RECORDS. AND WE BUT
WE HAD A CASE LIKE THIS THE
PERSON WAS DEAD TO RIGHTS HE
QUIT I HOPE YOU DIDN'T START
WORKING FOR ANOTHER AGENCY.
DOCTOR CORPS. WITH THAT AS
WHICH I CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
FOR ABOUT THANK OUT ON A ROLL
CALL WITH MISS BETWEEN NA
VOTING THANK YOU AFTER THANK
YOU MISS RAMOS. AB SEVENTEEN
SAN FIVE ENJOY THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. MEMBERS AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE REQUIRES
A DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE BE
NOTIFIED WHEN THE CHANGES MADE
TO A LOCAL LAND USE PLAN THAT
IMPACTS AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER CALDERON A SECOND BY
MISTER RIVAS. CONSTANT ON THIS
BILL ARE MINIMAL OR MINOR AND
OBSERVABLE. ARE THERE SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO FILE. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL THINK MISS RIGHT
THANK YOU CRISTINA GARCIA. YOU
HAVE AB FOR SIXTY FOUR IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
YOU WANNA START WITH THAT ONE
YES THEY THANK YOU- THERE'S NOT
THIS WILL IMPACTS ON THIS BILL
AB FOR SIXTY FOUR SIMPLY
REQUIRES THAT WE INCLUDE
CASTRATO WILDFIRES. I THINK SHE
WOULD'VE AIR POLLUTION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE WE HAVE THEM BY DOCTOR
EGGMAN AS BY DOCTOR QUIRK
SPEAKER IN SUPPORT. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. DEPART OF FINANCE.
NO FOR. I SEE NO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. RESPECT ASK FOR IN A
THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT ON A
CALL YOU'RE NOW BILL IS A BE A
FOR FIVE AM A DO PASSED. THANK
YOU AB ELEVEN FORTY FIVE THIS
DOWN COLOR MOTION BY DON'T
CORPUS BY MISS CARILLO SIMPLY
THAT MANDATE REPORTERS SHOULD
TREAT ALL THE WITH ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE SPEAKERS IN SOME. WAS
AN HOMES ARE PUTTING THE POOR
BEHAVIOR SCIENCE AND SOME. I
MENTALLY YOU THE CALIFORNIA'S
LIKE. SO IN SUPPORT. ARE THERE
SPEAKERS AND- SEEN NONE SEE NO
QUESTIONS WHICH I CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL WITH MR CHOW I MISS
PETRIE-NORRIS NOT VOTING MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN VOTING NO. THANK
YOU. MISS WICKS. AB SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE. IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION I'M SORRY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MOTION BY MISTER CALDERON A
SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK GRATEFUL
YES FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA BE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL. ABOUT THE PERFECT
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO FILE.
WHICH I TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR. THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL MISTER NOT VOTING
MUST BE DREAM NORTH NOW THANK
YOU. MR RIVAS WOULD YOU. DO YOU
A BILL YES WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO
FOR I HAD THE RIGHT RIVAS.
WE'RE GOING START WITH AB SIX
TWENTY AND THE TO PAY
RECOMMENDATION A WAS MOVED BY
MISTER CALDERON AND SECOND BY
DOCTOR QUIRK SO- APPRECIATE-
THE QUICK MOTION SIXTY THREE
SIX RELATE TO THE CIGARETTE
FIRE SAFETY ACT RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I. SPUR MARIO DO. ON
BEHALF OF THE GENERAL TO SERRA
PROUD SPONSOR THIS BILL.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE FILE SEE NO
QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE BUT LAST FOREVER CHECK IT
OUT ON A BEER CALL NOW IS A SIX
TWENTY SEVEN ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER CALDERON.
ASSEMBLY BILL SECOND FIND
CENTER QUIRK. I'M SORRY ON THE
PREVIOUS BILL IT GOT OUT ON B.
ROLL CALL WITH MISS DOLLY
ABSTAINING AND WE'RE BACK TO
THIS BILL THAT HAS A CUT MOTION
SIXTEEN TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO
IS RELATED TO ENHANCEMENTS TO
THE CALIFORNIA BACK STATUTE
OVER MAINTAIN OUR STATE TOBACCO
DIRECT AND RESPECT LAST NIGHT.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT MARIO DE
BERNARDI ON BEHALF OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE YOU EVER
SAT. SPONSOR THIS BILL.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE BY
THAT'S BEEN ABOUT MANAGER IN
THAT COULD TURN THE ROLL CALL
YEAH. ANY MISS LACKEY. ALL
RIGHT IN THE MEANTIME. SO THE
CHAIR HAS AB THIRTEEN FIFTY. WE
HAVE A MOTION AND WE HAVE A
SECOND. WE'LL GIVE THE CHAIR A
MOMENT TO APPROACH THIS A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY MISTER BROWN AND
EIGHT YES OF. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. DID REALLY
YOU DON'T WANT TO TELL AS THE
LIEN CD I THOUGHT I HAD A
MOTION AND A SECOND THIS IS TO
ENSURE WE USE BUS PASSES THAT'S
GREAT DO YOU LOVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. WE IN OP. HOW ARE TO
FINANCED YOU HAVE ANY NO FILE
NO FILE KIND SO SHOCKED. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS SAY NINE
THIS GETS OUT ON AND ROLL CALL.
LATELY YOU'RE GOING TO PRISON
ON SB A SEVEN YEAH AS TWO IS BY
SENT TAUGHT THOUGH I. HAS
URGENT CLASS IN THAT WHY WE
MOVE SENT BILL TO. IT WAS THE
PROCESS FOR VOTER UPDATING.
PERSONAL INFORMATION OR PARTY
PREFERENCE LEADING UP TO AND
INCLUDING ON ELECTION DAY- AS
WE GET CLOSER THE PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARY WE KNOW FROM PAST
EXPERIENCES THAT VOTERS WILL
HAVE OBSTACLES IN NAVIGATING
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTORAL PROCESS
WE ALSO KNOW WE HAVE SPECIAL
PRIMARY RULES FOR THE
PRESIDENTIAL AND SO IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT I ADD TO INSURE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TOO MANY
PROVISIONAL BALLOTS THAT PEOPLE
CAN ACTUALLY. I'M I TEST
CHANGED THE REGISTRATION UP TO
AN ON THE DAY OF THE ELECTION
SO IF THEY'D LIKE TO VOTE THE
REPUBLICAN PRIMARY BUT THEY ARE
IN AND P. P. VOTER- THEY CAN DO
SO. AT THE- LOS ON THE COUNTY
VOTE AND WILL HELP AND I WE DO
SO TIMES OF POLLS EVERY NUMBER
BALLOT TO RESPECT. FOR NINE.
SHARE WITH THE- RED. THE SECOND
WORK ON WE HAVE A MOTION AND ON
DO YOU HAVE ANY STE IN SUPPORT
STE SPEAKERS IN OFFICE. ROB
AVALON HERE BEHALF AS STATE
OUTS BUT THE SPA GOING SUPPORT.
MY ANGER MAY SEE OF IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT AROUND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA'S AS A CLARKSON FISH
IN SUPPORT. AB IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE THE PART OF FINANCE
NO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
QUESTIONS OF THE FROM THE MEN
SEEING NO ONE REALLY TO THE
CALL THIS GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL. SO WE'RE STILL AWAITING
MR LACKEY. OKAY SO WHAT'S HIS.
ALL. I THINK MISTER DOCTOR IS
ONE TO PRESENT LACKEY BILL IF
THAT'S A PLEASES THEM SURE THAT
FINE I WAS SINCE WAY PRESS ON
BUT YOU CAN'T WAIT PRESENTATION.
SO WE HAVE A SO YOUR BACK. AB
FOR FIFTY IS A TO PASS
RECOMMEND IT'S BEEN MOVED. I
MISTER BRO IN THIS BY MISTER
BIG. ENJOY THE PAST RECOMMEND.
OR THIS. SAYS THAT IS SO IS
INVEST F. A SEXUAL CHILD IF
SHE'S ME IF CHILD. IS THE TO BE
SO. BY THE OF. IT WOULD GO WITH
THE CHILD CENTRO INDIA SO WE
CAN MAKE SURE THE THOSE ARE
MUSICIANS TO ABUSE CHOI AGAIN.
ALL RIGHT OTHER SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. MANAGER BRENDAN UP ON
BEHALF OF THE SPONSOR LA COUNTY
PARDON SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SPEAKER IN OPPOSITION. THERE
DEPARTMENT OF FINE MISTER LACK
DR SO NICELY PRESENTED TO BILL.
COME ON UP. YOU COME ON UP AS
WE DISPENSE OF IN HIS OWN HAS
ANY OF. HE A FABULOUS JOB HAS A
MOTION AND A SECOND. AND NO.
WITH WE'LL GO AND TAKE THAT IS
CLOSE. YES THANK YOU THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL WITH MISTER
BONTA NOT VOTING. THEY ARE YOU
CAN YOURSELF A BILL. THANK YOU.
NOW AT THIS WE READ THE- IN
WILL BE SENT TO THIS IS FILE
AND SECRETARY. AB 667-152-6220
TO SIX THREE SIXTIES FOUR
NINETY NINE FOR THIRTY FIVE BY
COULD NINE BUT YOU. TO SIXTY
SEVEN SIX NINETY NINE EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT FIFTY FIVE NINE
FOUR NINE SIX NINE  991-525-1550
TWO IF SIXTY SEVEN FIFTEEN FOUR
AND SIXTEEN SIXTY. GRAY IF
THERE IS ANYBODY IN THE
AUDIENCE WHO HAD- WANTED TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION TO A BILL THAT WAS
MOVED TO THE SUSPEND FILE- YOU
MAY DO SO NOW. IF YOU MEN'S AND
FIND OUT WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
BILL. IT'S UP TO YOU. ARE WE
REGISTER IN SUPPORT OKAY PLEASE
THERE YOU GO. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA PROUD COAT
PROUD SPONSOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO SIXTEEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT AT THIS POINT WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE INTO OUR
SUSPENSE FILE HEARING. GOOD
MORNING AGAIN. AND WELCOME TO
THE JANUARY TWENTY THIRD
ASSEMBLY PREPARATION SUSPENSE
HEARING I WANT TO THANK MY VICE
CHAIR AS USUAL- FOR THE
COOPERATION AND MOVING THESE
THINGS TOWARD NOW THAT SHE'S
HERE WE WILL OFFICIALLY WELCOME.
THE CONGRESS WILL. SORRY
ASSEMBLY DOLLY I. GIVE YOUR DE
TITLE YEAH WHAT WELCOME TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT THE SYSTEM FILE
APPROPRIATIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER VIDEO. IT'S REALLY CLEAR
WHAT HAPPENS HERE. I WANT IT
ALSO DAHLE MY CALL FOR HARD
WORK ON READING THESE BILLS
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE I KNOW IT
WAS A TIME CRUNCH THIS THIS
JANUARY AND I THINK WE GOT
THROUGH ALL OF THEM ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER I WOULD THINK THE
PREPARATION STAFF IN THE
REPUBLICAN FISCAL SCAT STAFF
FOR THEIR HARD WORK IT REALLY
HAS BEEN- A LOT. VERY QUICKLY.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO ANNOUNCE THAT
AS- AFTER TRYING IT OUT LAST.
LAST TIME WE ARE NOW. RE DOING
THE BILL PACKETS IN THE
ASSEMBLY. APPROPRIATIONS TO
ALWAYS. BE ORGANIZED BY AUTHOR
NOW BUT A QUARTER. ONLINE IT IS
SIMPLY APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE WHICH IS LOCATED AT
EIGHT P. R. O. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT
CA DOT. G. O. V. LATER THIS
AFTERNOON FOLLOWING TODAY'S
HEARINGS THE COMMITTEE WILL
POST AN OFFICIAL RESULTS TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE HEARING. ON THAT
SAME WEBSITE. HELLO IS THERE
ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE SAY ME WE
GETS. FIRST I DO LIKE TO
WELCOME OUR NEW MEMBER. GOOD TO
SEE YOU MISS- DALLY AND- AS
CHAIR JUST SAID. HAVE FUN
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WHAT
HAPPENS HERE. IS BECAUSE IT'S
ENTERTAINING BUT I DO WANT TO
THANK ALL THE MEMBERS AS THE
CHAIRED IT- THIS WAS A VERY
SHORT NOTICE IT WAS VERY
CHALLENGING A LOT OF READING
HERE FOR US. AT LAST MINUTE AND
FOR ALL THE STAFF THAT. ARE
BEHIND THE SCENES THANK THEM
VERY MUCH FOR THEIR DUE
DILIGENCE AND GETTING DONE AND
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIRED.
STAFF IN PARTICULAR FROM. WITH
MY STAFF. ON TRYING TO RESOLVE
A LOT OF THE ISSUES THAT WE
FACE. AND MEDICARE. THANK YOU.
FOR THE DAY LET'S GO FOR. THAT
WEIRD IF EVERYBODY HAS A PACKET
WE'RE GONNA START WITH AB FIFTY
SIX FIFTEEN SIXTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY A
BILL REGARDING ORGANIC WASTE
THIS BILL ENJOYS A
RECOMMENDATION OF DO PASSED I
HAVE A MOTION. NO BIGGIE YOU
DON'T WANNA DO THE DOCTOR
QUICKER TO THE MùT. AND THIS
IS. NOW BECAUSE I WANT TO READ
THE HEAD START CALDERON. WILL
SECOND. OCEAN BACK IN OUT ON A
ROLL CALL OF WILL SO THEM AND-
FOR ALL THE DO PASS OR DO
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS ON THE
REST OF THE SUSPENSE FILE. YES
SAGE AND. WITH THE- MOVING ON
AB FOR FIVE NINE ARAMBULA THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER PER WAIT DO
PASSED ON APRIL CALL AB FIFTY
NINETY FOUR BAUER-KAHAN
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATION SUPPORTS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. AB SEVENTY BERMAN
NONPROFIT COLLEGE APPROVAL TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY TWO BLOOM SOLID WASTE
FLUSHABLE PRODUCTS DO PASSED
WITH AMENDMENTS TO NARROW THE
BILL TO THE LABELING PROVISIONS
ONLY THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL. AB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX
BOERNER HORVATH SANTA NO FREE
STATE BEACH DO PASSED WITH THE
MEMBERS TO CLARIFY CALTRANS A
SORTIE THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
SEVEN THIRTY TWO BONTA COUNTY
JAILS IN PREGNANT INMATES DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO PRESERVE THE
RIGHT OF INMATES TO REFUSE
PREGNANCY TESTING TO PROTECT
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE SERVICES
AND ELIMINATE SPECIFIC MANDATES
ON COUNTY JAILS THAT GETS OUT
WITH THE REPUBLICANS NOT VOTE
IN. EIGHTY NINE SIXTY SIX BONTA
MEANT PLANTS HOLDING COMMITTEE
AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE BOROUGH
PROFESSIONAL LICENSE FEE INCOME
TAX CREDIT HOLDING COMMITTEE
EIGHTY TWO FIFTY NINE CALDERON
VEHICLE REGISTRATION HOLD IT.%
THREE EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY THREE
CARILLO ASK TEST FOR MEDI CAL
ELIGIBILITY DO PASS. ON ANY
CALL. EIGHT I DID TELL YOU THAT
YOU YEAH YEAH. WHERE RUSTY WAS
MEETINGS NEXT. AB FORTY
CERVANTES LOW FORGET PROGRAM
COMMITTEE AB TWO NINETY ONE TWO
AMER PREPAREDNESS THAT WAS
KANSEN CHU DO PASSES AMENDED TO
THE PRO AND MODIFY OVERSEE THAT
COULD OUT WITH THE REPUBLIC NOT
THOUGH. AB EIGHT EIGHTEEN
COOLEY LOCAL GOVERNMENT VLF
HOLE COMMITTEE EIGHT ONE FIFTY
COOPER CREDIT FOR HIGH
GRADUATION PASS ON A ROLL AB
SIXTY SEVENTY REAL BROKER
LIMITED COMPANIES TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL AB EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT
EGGMAN SMALL PHARMACIST DENSE
DO PASS AS AMENDED MAKE
CONTINGENT ON THE BUDGET THAT
GETS OUT OF IT YOU ROLL CALL AB
THIRTY THREE SIXTY SEVEN FLORA.
PRESENCE A CARE FACILITIES NOT
ACCEPTABLE CRIMES HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB FORO EIGHT FRAZIER
VEHICLES DISABLED VETERANS DAY
PASSED WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
REMOVE MODIFICATIONS TO THE
CURRENT DEFINITION OF LABELED
VETERAN THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL AB TWO SEVENTY SIX
FRIEDMAN PARENTAL NOTIFICATION
A FIREARM SAFETY LAWS TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL AB THREE TWENTY
TWO GALLAGHER POLITICAL REFORM
ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
ONLINE FILING AND DISCLOSURE
STONE. DO PASSED WITH TO CHANGE
POSTING JUST TWO HOURS FROM
RECEIPT BACK TO TOWN ON ROLL
CALL AB THIRTY ONE CHRISTINE
GARCIA TAMPA TAX TO PASS AS A
MAN EXT THE EXAMS TO TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN AB AND SIX CARS.
THAT GETS OUT OF THE ROLE. AB
NINE SIX EIGHT CRISTINA. NASH
WORK MODEL CURRICULUM MEDI
EIGHT FIVE EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY
GROW. FLEEING THE SCENE OF AN
ACCIDENT PASS ON A ROLL. AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY AND WE GARCIA
ACOSTA EFFECTIVE. DEFINITION
COMMITTEE AB SIXTY SIX IT IS
ALL. A DIAPER TAX EXAM DO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL. AB SIX NINE
GRACE CREDIT REPAIR TO PASS ON
A NEIGHBOR. AB THIRTY THREE
HOLD TAX CLUES WATERY HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB SIXTY NO WAIT BACK
CHECK DO YOU AS AMENDED
APPROACH DS FROM IN APP TO DO
CRIMINAL HIS. DURING THE
INITIAL PROCESS AND CHANGED
DATA REPORTING THAT GETS OUT ON
A B. ROLL CALL. AB EIGHT TWENTY
TWO IRWIN PHLEBOTOMY HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB FIFTY FIVE JONES
SAWYER CANNABIS BANKING TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL AB EIGHT FIFTY
LACKEY SOCIAL WORKER STUDENT
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB EIGHTEEN LEVINE
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION TAX
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB SEVEN
NINETY LEVINE PERSONAL SERVICES
TO PAST AS AMENDED TO REPLACE
WAGE STANDARD WITH A
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENT. LEN
SORRY GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL. AB SEVEN. NINETY SIX. AB
SEVENTY NINETY SIX LEVINE
COMMUNITY CARE FACILITIES
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECKS TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB TEN
SEVENTY ONE LOW MOAN OF GRANTS
FOR ADD CLIMATE ADAPTATION
TOOLS TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO THE MON
NATIVE AMERICAN STUDIES MODEL
CURRICULUM FUNDING TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
LOW ELECTION DAY HOLIDAY HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB SIXTEEN SIXTEEN
LOW EXPENSE CONVICTIONS TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL AB TWO TWENTY
SIX MATHIS SPECIALIZED LICENSE
PLATES HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
FOR NINETY NINE MAYES STATE
AGENCIES PERSONAL INFORMATION
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL AB SIX
FORTY SIX MCCARTY ELECTION
VOTER ELIGIBILITY FOR PAROLEES
DO PASSED WITH TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS ON A B. ROLL CALL.
AB EIGHT FIFTY FIVE MCCARTY DOJ
POLICY POLICIES ON THE USE OF
DEADLY FORCE HOLDING COMMITTEE
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT MCCARTY
HOUSING LAWS STATE GRANTS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB EIGHT
NINETY SEVEN MEDINA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PART TIME EMPLOYEES DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO MOVE THE
OPERATE YOU DID THAT WITH
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO MOVE
THE DATE OF OPERATION. THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB
NINE FOUR MEDINA COUNTY JAILS
VISITATION HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
NINE FORTY MELENDEZ PATIENT
BROKERING HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
THREE TWENTY SIX MURATSUCHI
MOTORIZED CARRYING DEVICES DO
PASSED WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
TO SPECIFY DMB DOES NOT NEED TO
UPDATE THE CALIFORNIA DRIVER'S
HANDBOOK EARLY. I GETS OUT ON
ANY ROLL CALL. AB THREE FORTY
FIVE MERRICK TO CHEAP OIL AND
GAS OPERATIONS. LOCATION
RESTRICTIONS DO YOU PASSED WITH
THE AMENDMENTS TO DELETE THE
CONTENTS OF THE BILL AND
INSTEAD PROVIDE DIRECTION TO
CAL JAM TO DEVELOP REGULATION
INCLUDING REQUIRING A SETBACK
IN THE CONSIDERATION OF TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED FOOT SETBACK AT
SCHOOLS PLAYGROUNDS AND PUBLIC
FACILITIES WHERE CHILDREN ARE
PRESENT. DIRECTLY SECRETARY OF
NATURAL RESOURCES TO DEVELOP AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE PROGRAM
INCLUDING A GRANT PROGRAM TO
ALLOW E. J. GROUPS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE AGENCIES
REGULATORY PROCESS. THAT GETS
OUT ON A BE ROLL CALL. A FIVE
SEVENTY SIX NAZARIAN OF
EQUALIZATION HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB SIX FORTY EIGHT NECESSARY
AND WELLNESS PROGRAM DO PASSED
WITH AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS THE
USE OF DATA DEFINITION
PENALTIES AN AUTHORIZATION TO
ADOPT REGULATIONS AND ADD TO A
NARROW EXEMPTION AND OTHER
MINOR CHANGES THAT GETS OUT ON
A. B. ROLL CALL. NINE OH EIGHT
AB NINE OH WAIT BY MISTER
O'DONNELL PRACTICE ITEMS FOR
STUDENT TESTING TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT QUIRK CANNABIS TESTING DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REMOVE
PROVISIONS ALLOWING
MANUFACTURERS TO CONTEST
LABORATORY TEST RESULTS THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
NINE SEVENTY NINE RAY YES
EMERGING MANAGERS DO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB THREE NINETY FIVE
RUBIO FOSTER CHILDREN HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB TWO THIRTY EIGHT
SANTIAGO UNLICENSED AUTUMN UP
BILL DISMANTLE OURS TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL. AB ELEVEN FORTY
MARK STONE TAX PREPARERS
DISCLOSURES DO PASSES AMENDED
TO IMPROVE THE DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS MAKE OTHER
CLARIFYING CHANGES THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB NINE
WALDRON LOCAL ASSISTANCE GRANT
PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
TWO SIXTEEN WEBER PEOPLE AND
STAFF SAFETY PILOT PROGRAM TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB EIGHT
NINETY. NURSE PRACTITIONERS. DO
YOU PASSED AS AMENDED TO
REQUIRE NURSE PRACTITIONERS TO
INFORM NEW PATIENTS THEY ARE
NOT DOCTORS IN SPECIFIED THAT
SPANISH LANGUAGE TERM FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONER CLARIFY ONLINE
PROGRAMS DO NOT MEET STANDARDS
FOR CLINICAL TRAINING REQUIRED
AN EXAMINATION TO DEMONSTRATE
COMPETENCY PER THIRD PARTY
EXPERT RUBIO INCREASE PRACTICAL
TRAINING WORK EXPERIENCE
REQUIREMENTS AND OTHER
AMENDMENTS THAT GETS OUT WITH
THE REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AND
THAT KIND. OUR COMMITTEE. TODAY
THANK YOU ALL FOR PLAYING.